Good evening, sir.
Good evening, sir. Good evening, sir. Good evening, sir.
Good evening. Good evening. Good evening.
We wait for two minutes and then we'll start.
Alright, so let's start now. Okay.
Well, let's first quickly recap from
what we did in the last session.
So, uh, if you can record our, uh,
last session was mostly hands-on where we built
three different versions of the neural network
on our fashion evidence data set.
And I had shared the same, uh, with you in the, like,
those notebooks as well as the data set was shared with you.
So, um, let me just open that once
and then I'll quickly go through it.
Okay. So it was
second
tail and module.
Yeah, this one. Let me share my screen.
Okay. So, uh,
this is what we did.
So, uh, first of all,
these things we have already discussed.
Now, what I did in the last class,
we started from this slide, if you can recall,
I first explained what is this data set
and dataset loader class in PyTorch and what is their role?
And we understood that the dataset class is,
is used mainly to load the data.
Okay? So sometimes your data might, might be in one form,
sometime in another form.
Now, this dataset, cl plus, uh, help us to load,
load the data, whatever we have in whichever format we have,
and convert them into the tens.
Because ultimately in everything we do as a tensor,
that is the data pipe what we want.
So in the data dataset class, we saw
that we have these three, uh, methods.
The init method, the length method, and the get item method.
So in it method is by default, it, it's a constructor.
So whenever we will make any object of this dataset class,
this constructor will get called automatically.
And inside the constructor, we mainly do the loading
of the data in the form of tens.
That's all. Now this length
and get items, these two are the function, which is,
which is, uh, which is utilized by the other
other class that is called dataset loader class.
Okay? So dataset loader class.
Main job is to make the batches mini batches.
Okay? So what it does,
suppose you have a hundred rows in my data
it first ask this dataset class to returns
total length means total number of rows in the dataset.
So then this length will return a hundred
dataset loader takes one parameter, okay?
What is the size of each batch you want?
So if it is 32, then it just simply divide a hundred by 32
and those mini mini batch gets formed.
Now, once the mini batches are created, find, so how to, uh,
how mini batch size is created, we have
to now create those mini batch of data means the rules for
that one, this gate item is used.
So whatever index we feed to the dataset class,
it returns those rules, okay?
Because what we do
before creating the mini batches, we shuffle the data.
It, that means that suppose I have
to create the mini badge of 32.
I don't, I don't go on creating
the samples like row number zero to row number th uh,
31 as one mini badge
and row number 32, then 61 as another mini badge.
We don't go serially first we shuffle the dataset,
and then we see that, okay, what are what, 32 data,
which is coming in the first 32 positions.
Index can be anything.
And those index, we ask from this get
item function to returns.
And that's how we get the mini batches.
That's why this dataset
and data dataset loaded these two are the different
classes we had seen.
Okay? So in a nutshell, dataset is used.
Dataset class is used to load your data in the form
of tens and dataset.
Loader class is used
to convert those data in the form of mini batches.
That is what is the main role of these two. Okay?
Now we also talked about
how these then mini batches is used in the training
loop at the time of the training.
So what we do, we fetch the data batch by batch
because we have already created those mini batches.
So what we do in the training loader
and test loader, we have those mini batches ready
at the training loop.
We fetch those batches from the train loader in the form
of a loop, one by one.
Those batches will come, X batch will have the features,
y batch will have the labels,
and that's how that then we will go on
doing all those things like forward propagation, okay?
And all the rest of the things, whatever is required
for the, uh, training of our neural network.
Okay? So this was the, uh, uh,
first we understood these two, uh, classes,
which is available in PyTorch.
And then we took an example use case
of this fashion AMS dataset where our dataset was,
uh, data, actual dataset was image,
but the, it was given in the form of CSV in the form
of pixels, okay?
And we built this network, 7 84,
which was the input because 28 plus 28 image size.
So 7 84 pixels.
So in the input we have 7 84, uh, inputs
represents the pixels of the image.
Then in this hidden one, we have 1 28 neurons.
In this hidden two layer, we have 64 neurons,
and in the output 10 neurons, because we had 10 class.
Okay? Now, if you can recall this,
uh, we had first used this, we loaded the data, okay,
in the form of the data frame,
and then just showed you some of the samples that, how those
does our data look like.
We did then train test a split little feature scaling, okay?
Now custom dataset, this is
where we actually create our custom
dataset from dataset class.
And there was three method in method,
which is converting our data,
which we have already wrote in the, in the form
of tensors, okay?
With the flow 32, 32 data type
and labels also in the form of tensors.
And the type is long then length method and get item method.
This is also part of these, uh, of custom dataset,
which we have not called, uh, I immediately,
but when we next created the data loader class,
you see here, data loader class, actually internally,
it caused the custom data set.
Identify, okay, total, what is the length of my data means
how many rows are there in my data, divided
by whatever batch size you will give here, okay?
And then create those many mini badges. Okay?
That is what it does. Okay?
And then this, this, we have already seen it earlier also,
that how to create the neural network module in the,
this we have already seen, okay?
And uh, then rest of the things were same.
We came to the training loop in the training
loop ordered loop.
Decide how many epochs.
That means that for, uh,
every och there will be an update in those weights.
Whatever is the weights in your model.
Now, that would decided by how many epochs you want to run
and inside each epoch how many mini badge you have created.
Okay? So there are two for loop. You can see here.
Now, for each mini, uh, mini batch,
we first do the forward pass, then calculate the loss,
then do the backward pass, and then update the weight.
This is what we do in the neural network.
So these four steps, and finally we calculate the average
loss per oc, and that is what is listed here.
This is what we had seen.
And then we set our model model into the evaluation mode.
And on the test from the test load
loaded on the test dataset, we calculated
what is the accuracy, which is coming on test data.
So that was coming as 83%.
So this was the first version which I had shown you
and I mentioned it
that here I am using only a sample of data.
If you can see here, we used only 6,000 of 6,000 rules.
In fact, in the total data a file,
we had 60,000 rules, okay?
And we did the training completely on CPU
because our, uh, uh, data set was small,
we were able to do it quickly.
Now, as a second version, then, uh, we started exploring
that how to train the same network with GPU, okay?
And, but this time, uh, the plan was to use the entire
training, uh, entire data samples,
and we had 60,000 data samples,
60,000 rows in my data, okay?
So we said that it is doable,
but then there are few changes which we
have to do in our code.
First of all, we need
to check whether the GPU is available or not.
And with this code, we had checked whether the GPU is
available or not, correct?
And then what we did, whatever model we created, model, uh,
uh, uh, we created from my NN module,
we moved it to the device.
Device is representing the GPU
or cuda in this particular case.
So first of all, we checked whether this device
is available or not.
If yes, then we moved it to the device.
And device is nothing. But here, the GPU.
And then in the training loop,
we did some changes in the sense once we are extracting
batch feature, batch label from the train loader
and later part in the test loader
before going into the forward pass,
and then calculating laws, doing ev, everything else,
what we do, first of all, we move the data to the GPU,
these, these batches also, we have to move to the GPU, okay?
And for that, again, the code is very simple.
Whatever batch features we are getting, we just have
to write dot two device.
Okay? Two device means we are moving it
to this particular device,
and this device is nothing but gp.
Similarly, for label also, this is one change.
Similarly, for the test loader,
when we are doing the evaluation,
we had done two device part in these two lines, okay?
And then again, I had shown you the next, uh,
version of this.
Let me just open now here, what I, what I did, first of all,
I loaded the entire data sample, okay?
Entire data sample, 60,000 rows I can show you here.
So first of all, I checked with this line of code,
whether the GPU is available or not.
Very simple to device, you just have
to write this one conditional statement.
It'll save that the COURA
or CPU on which device you're working.
So because we had set it to, uh, runtime to GPU,
so it showed that we are running on the kuda means CPU,
then we read the entire data sample.
That is 60,070.
Column wise, there is no change,
but row wise, we now used 60,000 data samples, okay?
Or roads, you can say that. Okay?
These just a sample of data which we showed,
and again, these two steps were the same.
We divided the data into train
and validation train, test split, then normalized it, okay?
Here, there was no change in the custom data set
where we converted our data in the form
of tensors labeled in the form of tensors, right?
And then we called the data loader class in the same way.
There was no change in that.
Now, in the my, once we built our neural network,
there was also no change in the neural network.
Again, one sequential layer where sequential container,
where we have one linear layer followed by relu,
another linear layer followed by relu.
And finally, the output layer, the same thing,
which I showed you in the slide.
Okay? And finally, what we did, uh,
while creating the object of high model, in the next slide,
I wrote red wrote model models model dot two device.
That means that we are again, moving the model into the GPU,
but this part is required whenever you want to use the GPU.
Okay? Then in the training loop, this one lineup change,
we did, as I said, move the data to the GPU model.
VID now data to the GPU.
In the earlier case, if you can see,
we did not have this code, uh, here,
after extracting the batch feature,
batch labels from train loader, we are simply feeding you
to the model for the prediction.
And that's then lost calculation and backward.
But here, what we are doing is
before feeding you to the model for the prediction, first,
we are moving the data to gpu.
So this line, one line of code we have done
for the feature also for the label.
So we moved it to the GPU for the GPU users, then trained
with the complete 60,000 data.
And in the evaluation also, we did the same exercise,
this one, okay?
Now one more thing, which I have showed you in,
in this notebook was evaluation, uh, uh, uh,
the training accuracy.
Earlier case, it was coming as if I, uh,
just know I showed you it was coming as it was coming, uh,
as point 83%.
But when we use with the GPU, it was coming as 88%.
Okay? Because now again, the reason was
because we use the entire data sample earlier.
We use only 6,000 here, we use 60,000 data sample, right?
So obviously the training accuracy has improved. Oh, sorry.
Testing accuracy has improved.
Now, in this case, what we did, we also checked
what is the training accuracy means.
At the training time, what was the accuracy?
And we found that the training time accuracy was
98% testing time.
It was 88%.
And this is where, if you re recall,
we discussed the concept of over fitting, over fitting.
And we say that in such a case where you see
that there is a huge gap between the training accuracy
and testing accuracy.
You have to understand that my model is under the over
overfit condition,
and you need to optimize your neural network model in order
to reduce the overfit problem, okay?
And there are multiple ways of doing that,
that you can add more data, which we did not do
because 60,000
and that was the only data sets we have been given.
And we don't have much data because many case it'll happen.
You don't have immediately more data
to train your model further, okay?
But this is one such solution,
and it may reduce your over fitting a little bit.
Then reduce model complexity in the sense,
suppose you have two hidden layer, you keep it
to only one hidden layer, okay?
Less than one hidden layer.
Anyway, it'll not make much, make much, much sense.
Even in fact, what we discussed,
two hidden layer is also not a very complex network.
So maybe reducing the model complexity also will
not solve our problem.
That is what we understood what we discussed,
although we can try this, but we did not do
in the previous class.
But this is one another solution
for reducing the over fitting.
Early stopping means you, uh, for
after every oc you also check that, uh,
after every oc you check what is training accuracy also,
and validation accuracy also.
And you, wherever you see that in the training,
accuracy is not improving.
You stop there itself. Don't train for more number of,
so you do early stopping.
Maybe that will have some control over the
over fitting, okay?
That is what, uh, another solution says,
which we have not yet tried.
We'll see that in future, if we can try that.
Then the next thing is the dropout.
Um, uh, next thing is dropout, where, uh,
actually we use this, this method, okay?
We use this dropout method, batch normalization method
and regularization method.
So in the dropout, what happens for a particular head layer,
we drop some of the neurons.
Okay? So, uh, what happens while, uh, if we drop
randomly some neurons, we are making, uh,
for every batch we are make, we are doing this practice.
That means that for every batch, it may happen
for first batch, this neuron is dropped for the next batch,
first neuron would be dropped for the next batch.
Third neuron would be dropped. But randomly it is happening.
So what is happening? Every batch is seeing different neural
network, okay?
Every batch is seeing somehow different neural network.
So it tried to capture different aspects
of the input, okay?
And it's not trying to memorize the input,
and that helps the neural network in order to generalize
and reduce the overfeeding problem.
Okay? So that's, that, that's what we used, uh, dropout.
And we also used the patch normalization. We say that, okay?
Before, uh, once we do the linear, uh, uh,
um, linear function in a linear, uh, process,
that means weight, some plus bias as J one and jet two,
before passing it through the activation function,
you apply the batch normalization.
What it does, suppose jet one value is too high.
Jet two value is too slow. Then batch normalization.
It, it brings these, these activations, these jet one
and jet two in a within range, so that it'll go to,
if it'll go to the next activation function like relu,
they will not see these two value as very away.
They, for them, these two value are very close
between a range of zero to one or whatever.
It's, and hence it, uh, hence, it'll,
it'll normalize the network again.
Okay? So that is the concept.
So again, it helps in the, in bringing the, uh, our fitting
a little bit, uh, low.
Finally, we also talked about the
L two regularization.
L two ization is represented by this particular formula
where total loss is equal to loss,
which is coming from data.
And then we added some, uh, lambda into WIS squared.
So we said that, uh, uh, that
by adding this particular parameter,
we are reducing the weight.
Uh, we are trying to, uh, uh, control our weight
because the WI represent the weights, say a hundred weights.
So all, all a hundred weights, W one, W2, W three,
for every weight, we are having this lambda component.
What this lambda component does,
if some weights are very high, somehow it is controlling
that one so that that weight will not dominate, okay?
In, in, at, at the time of the back replication.
So all these things are the factors, okay?
So what we did in the third version, what we saw that, uh,
everything was same, there were three change.
What we then did in the, in the, in the notebook,
all these things were same.
All these things were same here.
The first change was in terms of the neural network itself.
So we added the badge normalization here
before passing to the relu, I added a badge, normalization,
and after the relu, we added the dropout layer.
So these two are the layers.
What we added similarly for the second neural, uh, thick
and hidden, hidden layer, batch normalization, we added 10
and then dropout, okay?
So this is what is the change,
what we introduce in the neural network
and in terms of batch normalization and dropout.
And one more change was in the optimizer
where we are actually updating our parameters.
But in the parameter update, what we said that we will,
we will add, uh, this, this, uh, this, um,
regularization that is the L two regularization.
And how did we do that?
We did it using, uh,
We did it using this, uh, we dk which,
what parameter called we dk, which we, uh, that is nothing
but lambda, which is called to 10, to the per minus
port, okay?
With this change, when we again, did the training loop,
there was no change, but we simply trained our network.
And in the evaluation,
we eval evaluated our model for the test.
Data accuracy was same pointed,
but for the train data, we saw that accuracy reduced to 93%.
In the earlier case, it was 98% for the train data,
but now it has reduced to 93.
So now we could able to reduce the gap between the, uh,
this, this, uh, data, this, uh, uh, test accuracy
and train accuracy.
Okay? This is what we, uh, we did that, that is
what we did in, in the previous class.
Okay? So, so far, this is what we have covered.
Now, I will, I will just stop for a while
for your questions, and then we will see that
what we have for today's class.
Yes. Uh, so first question, I have few questions
regarding Yes, yes.
So first question is that how q uh,
qda function identifies the GPU, sir.
So it is me, uh, function in me as
that it identifies the GPU.
And once data is loaded on the GPU, how it,
once we stop the processing, then whether it is on the GPU
or the data is released from the GPU, sir,
What was the first question? I did not hear. So
How qda identifies the system.
We have GPU in that, in our system,
it is a hardware, no, sir,
It is a hardware. So that's
why what we do the TOS directly, uh,
there is a device function, okay?
Yes, sir. Like we have a function called
regional school CSV,
and it understand that my file is in the,
in the form of the CSV.
Okay? Yes, sir. Similarly,
the torch has a function called device.
Now, what it does, it, it identify in this collab notebook
that, okay, what is the runtime?
Because you must be having a GPU
or CPU on which your program will actually run.
Yes, sir. So It identifies you.
And so if you want further, uh, what is this?
You can go and explore this function on the PyTorch.
Actually, it has the whole, uh, uh, uh, definition
that how this function is defined.
So this class is already defined in the PyTorch,
just have a look into it.
Yes, yes. But, uh,
but, uh, this is a simplified function,
which checks the same thing, whether your system,
right now it is using GP
or CCP internally, even, I don't know how it goes
and, uh, explore that one.
But you can go and check further this documentation,
what it has, okay? Yeah,
Sure.
And another, yes.
Second, second thing is that what you asked, uh, uh,
regarding that, once suppose we, uh, done with the training
and all and everything, whether the, uh,
still we are using GPU or CPU?
Yes. The answer is, unless you don't close that,
you're still, uh, using that GPU
unless you are not opting out by yourself.
Yes, sir. For example, sir, if we are using in our laptop,
not in, uh, collab notebook, uh, then in that case how
to release the data from GPUs.
Is there any function so that we can run?
I guess there must be some function.
I, I'm not sure about what is that function,
but you can see that one.
If you don't want to use GPU, there must be some function.
Just do that. Uh, ask that GP, it'll tell you one line
of one line of code. That's all.
Uh, yes, that's sure, sir. And
I have not used, Yeah.
Yes. A another question is regarding,
and the, uh, which we are using
to train the neural network,
different parameters like dropout, regularization and all.
So when we are using, uh, dropout
and, uh, regularization, um, bash, bash normal.
Mm-hmm. So, uh, can we use in the combination, sir,
because previous I had idea, either we can use dropout
or something like that, or batch normalization.
But here I'm saying that, um, we are using bash normal also
and dropout also.
So at which position we, we'll decide
before relu we'll use, um, batch normalization
after relu, we, or before linear, we'll use dropout.
So the usual practices, uh, that's what I,
I explained it in the last class.
The usual practices. Yeah,
I was not there, sir. Sorry, Uhhuh,
That's what, so, uh, drop dropout we usually use
here, if you can see here, dropout is after the activation.
So in a, in a particular layer, you have a neuron.
Neuron does two operation.
First, the linear operation
where it is doing the weighted sum
and then followed by activation function.
These are the two operation dropout we use
after the, uh, activation,
after the active, you can see that
after relu I have used here.
That is a usual practice, okay?
Yes, sir. Yes. Now, uh, batch normalization,
the usual practice is to use before the activation.
That's why the batch norm is coming
after the here also here also, okay?
Yes, that is the usual practice,
but you may see there is slightly variations in that.
Also, certain times, maybe
after activation only,
both the things are being used as normal.
So dropper also, okay,
but I have given you the reason why this is a usual
practice, okay?
Because see, once, uh, what we do, we randomly
drop some neurons.
So whatever neurons you have to drop, okay?
That, uh, that, that, that call you take,
once you calculate all the neurons output,
and then you decide that, okay,
this neurons has something which I don't want to carry out,
you drop it, okay?
You drop it. So that's why the, usually the dropout has
after the all the functionality, what you have to, you have
to perform in the neuron usual practices.
That is what I'm saying. Okay?
But ization, why before the why before this,
because, uh, uh,
because to the activation function, whatever I want to pass,
I want to pass as a, as a normalized value.
So the activation function like sigmoid,
it should not see some value very high,
and it'll assign it to one
and very low, then it'll assign to zero,
then it'll be a problem for me.
Yes, Sir. That's why I just want to normalize
and then send, yeah, that is the main reason, okay?
Yes. So is there any way,
and that we can, for example,
they are having different layers.
Each cell is having different values.
So how, like in ml, uh, we can we come
to know which feature is more important?
So is there any way for dropout, I am asking specifically
to come to know that which neuron is less significant
and we can drop out something.
It's random operation.
Actually, the drop dropout operation is a random operation.
Obviously there are some intuition behind it.
Yes, sir. Okay. Yes,
Sir. But, uh,
I mean, manually we are not deciding
that which neuron we are going to drop
or which neuron we are not.
Uh, I would say that it is more like a random forest
where we weigh multiple trees.
Okay? Multiple trees we make based on some criteria where,
uh, why, uh, why choosing random,
random columns in from your features, you make the tree,
and then at the time of prediction,
you ask from all the tree, okay?
And then take them, uh, majority word count,
similar intuition is here we train batch wise
for each batch you make different neural network,
different neural network in the sense you drop some
of the neurons in between.
Architecture will be same,
but some neurons will be deactivated
and that we do randomly.
So that is the intuition what you can understand from here.
But there is no, uh, there is no, uh,
this operation is completely random.
This drop that which neuron will be dropped,
which neuro will not.
That is completely,
Yeah. Yes.
Thank you, sir.
What is the p value in the dropout? Like p
It says that how many neurons
or how many per, what is the percentage
of neuron in one layer would you want to drop?
Suppose 10 neurons you have kept three
neurons would be dropped.
Okay, sir, sir.
And the decision of dropping, like I have a bit
of a confusion, like sir, decision
of the dropping out happens
during the forward progression only, or like, uh, during
The only forward propagation only, okay,
at the means when means forward propagation note,
I would say that training time.
Yeah, training time, okay.
Because while training the network, this is what happens.
So at the training time, what happens
during the forward propagation, you drop some of the neuron,
get the output, and then
at in the backward propagation you update all the weights.
Okay? So,
but next time, again, for the next batch, again, you do
that, uh, drop some of the neurons obviously at the forward
propagation, but same thing doesn't have the happen at the
testing time because at the testing time,
also we do the forward propagation calculates the
prediction, but then you don't drop any, any neuron. Yeah.
So sir, when we are dropping,
suppose two neurons in the training time, so sir,
when we do the backward propagation,
do we update the weights of those neurons also,
or those are skipped?
Um, and no, I mean, see those, we, those are, uh, for, at,
for the backward propagation,
the connections looks the same, okay?
Uh, in the sense that connections are as it is only thing is
during the forward propagation, we don't give any, uh,
input, uh, any input to the next neuron and the next layer.
Okay? So from those, okay, sir,
but at the backward propagation, the way it is connected,
it, it goes, yeah, it goes as as it is, yeah.
Okay, sir. But I believe that, uh, yeah,
that whatever is the neural network we have built, I believe
that, uh, all the weights,
weights are being updated at the
backward propagation. Yeah.
Okay, sir. Thank you, Sir.
A small, uh, con uh, confusion, sir.
Uh, just what, uh, extending the Annie, uh, query in, uh,
in case of in forward, we are dropping the neurons, right?
Mm-hmm. And while in coming to the backward, uh,
propagation, uh, that neuron will not be there.
No, sir. When we drop it out, that one then how the weights
and all those people will get, uh,
That's what I was telling. You're
right, you're right. So what I was telling is
in the forward propagation, whatever neural network here,
because I said here by showing this particular thing, yes,
for example, say that this is one neural network.
Now, in this neural network,
this neuro neuron doesn't exist.
Exist, okay? So you have only these connections when you do
the forward this way, this way, this way,
this way will get updated.
So whatever is the neural network, which is, uh,
there in this batch,
or sorry, in that, in that, uh, what is that?
Uh, a forward propagation
and yeah, in that particular batch, suppose,
see, there are two, two things.
What you have to understand, there are two loops.
One was the, uh, uh, uh, epoch.
Inside the epoch, you have the mini batches, okay?
Inside the och, we have the mini batches.
So in, uh, when this inside the second loop,
when we are building here inside the second loop,
when we are building here, this one, this is
where the mini batches concept come,
and this is where those, uh, the,
this neural networks you are calling, okay?
Neural networks, you're calling. So what happened?
The backward propagation happened para epoch
wise, okay?
Backward propagation happens.
Uh, so para wise and inside this one, okay? Yeah.
So you, uh, yes. Now it is, uh, correct.
So backward propagation happened.
How many times here, suppose this is a hundred
that says one 50, so one 50
and 200 1500 times those many times backward, yes.
For each backward propagation, the only thing what you have
to consider that what is that neural network,
which was just, uh, which, which you have just used, okay?
Mm-hmm. Only that particular neural networks weight are
going to be updated
because for every batch, when you are doing the update, uh,
the neural network is different, okay?
And whatever is the neural network valid for
that particular mini batch?
Only those weights, uh, are being updated. Yes. Yes.
Not the, not the entire weight, correct? Yeah.
And one more doubt, sir.
I means, uh, if some means while calculating the loss, also,
uh, there will be a difference will be there, right, sir?
Depends, will be there. But then it is very simple, right?
Badge wise, we are calculating the loss.
Yes, whatever, whatever is the neural network,
suppose this neuron is not there,
will not consider whatever is coming from this,
but loss would be calculated by output.
Ultimately, you got the output, you, you store that output,
you store that output.
You don't see what happened in the mini batch cases.
Suppose you have four mini batch.
So for first batch, you calculate the output, you store it,
then second batch, you calculate this output is stored it.
Then third and fourth, what is the total output?
And then with that, you calculate the loss. That is one way.
Other way is for every batch, you calculate the loss
and calculate the average loss, okay?
Okay. But ultimately the loss is being calculated here.
It has no effect that, okay?
Whether you have dropped somewhere in between or not.
Okay? Okay.
Thank you, sir. Yes.
One, one question. Can you go back to that python?
Ask, pull up and yeah.
So here, um, you have a, a particular step
where you're adding relu and a dropout.
Solu in fact is also kind of dropping out, uh, um,
uh, is adding non-linearity,
but in a way is adding out, is keeping out some,
um, weights, right?
Or weights, or should I say neurons when they,
when they're less than zero?
Ah, correct, correct. That is true.
But, but something different. Okay?
Can, can, can, can be on and off.
I, I understand what you said,
but you don't know whether it'll be on or not
or whether it'll be offered not.
Okay? So it may happen that it will,
all the relu has the positive value, then all will go
as an input for the next layer, isn't it?
But by imposing the dropout, you say
that no compulsory 30% the neuron you have to drop.
So that is a difference.
If it may happen that relu also has three different negative
three neurons has coming with negative value, it'll also
not carry any information for the next layer,
but there is no guarantee that, uh, that will be the case.
But with the dropout, that will be the case always. Yeah.
So that is what it may happen, that okay,
relu the three neurons,
what you are selecting from the dropout
that anyway will drop three neurons,
and relu is also giving two neurons
where there is zero activation versus going for, in
that case, five neurons is not giving
any input to the next neuro.
All those combinations are possible. Yeah.
Okay. Yeah. Thank you.
So give an example. Uh, so batch normalization,
then we are applying a drop order.
So because of the dropout is a randomness, uh,
it's causing any noise, uh, in the system.
Uh, actually not in fact it is, uh, it, it is it,
it might be, it might be creating a noise,
but that noise is good for the, for to reduce
that over fitting, I would say.
Okay? Because ultimately we are trying
to solve the over fitting problem by imposing these layers
or these techniques, okay?
And, uh, by doing that one, what we are trying
to do is the main idea is
that it should learn the different behavior of them
because all the neural network here will get the same set
of input, same set of input.
Then if the neural network itself is different every time,
they will be learning different aspect of the input.
And that is what is more important,
rather than having only single neural network
and, uh, learning the same input again and again, again
and again, again and again.
Then it'll be a kind of memorizing,
memorizing the input, right?
That is what we want to, but noise, why?
It'll not come because, uh, uh, noise means
what in the sense, how will you introduce here the noise?
Actually we want to learn that variability, uh,
which I guess you have ident you are saying it as a noise
that is the different, uh, variety of the input, uh,
pattern, which we want to actually turn.
So I would say that is better
for the over fitting in this particular case,
and that is, that is shown in the experiment as well.
Yeah.
And this report, can we call it
as a regularization function?
Yeah. It is a kind of regularization, yes,
it's a kind of regularization.
There are other kind of regularization one L two also,
but you can treat this dropout as one of the type
of regularization for neural network.
Yes. Yes.
Any other query from anyone? Sir?
I have a question. How does, uh,
dropout affect, uh, convergence
Affect the convergence?
So as I said, uh, it, what it, uh, it, uh,
it, it is, I don't know, uh, whether you have, uh, gone
through in depth or this random forest
or not convergence, why BOC?
There are in, uh, 10 different neural networks, which are,
uh, instead of having one neural network, okay?
That is the main idea in this.
So as you can see, that for forces learning
of more learning feature, anything else?
I have no. So effect of au randomly disables neurons
during training prevents core adaption of neurons,
acts like training multiple network dropout is active
only during the node.
Okay? So convergence, we would say that
because for every epoch, the loss, what we are getting,
okay, and every epoch, we have multiple batches,
multiple neurons, they have seen neural network,
they have seen, and hence they, uh, uh,
what what they do.
Uh, uh, I, I believe
that the convergence in this particular case is, uh,
better than the case where we have not used the dropout
and it was having the over fitting problem.
Okay? That is what I understand it,
but, uh, it, it's convergence is linked
with the loss function.
You can see that loss function for every epoch.
We calculate the loss, and that is what we plot.
And you can now visualize again, that curve.
The convex curve loss is the one which we are seeing
that whether it is going toward the minimum global minimum
or not, that we calculates after, after every, every OC
or every, uh, mini batch, whatever you say.
And, uh, yeah, the convergence in the case of dropout,
I guess it is better than the, the case,
and it is, it is equivalent at the test time.
That is more important. That is what we are doing.
If it is not better also,
but then it is showing the similar kind of convergence
for test data as well on rather than only on the train data.
Yeah.
Okay. Sir, sir, uh, if you go for dropout,
the convergence is not becoming faster.
Now saying becomes slower,
Uh, see, because You are randomly selecting neurons
and you are, uh, discarding from the network.
So the entire network model has to adjust.
Now, sir, just so the convergence becomes slow.
No, I mean, see, I'll tell you, see,
once you are disabling this particular source,
so neural network doesn't, uh, uh, ut
for the neural network, it is good that one,
number one parameter is reduced.
See, if you talk in terms of the time, what happens just
because this neuron is not there,
the connection in this direction, this input
and output from this neuron, everything is gone.
Hence, it doesn't have to calculate the forward propagation
with respect to this particular edge as well
as at the backward propagation.
Also, it doesn't have to update this parameter.
Two things it'll not have to do, right?
And if not, then obviously time will be less, you think, in
that particular sense, right?
Uh, obviously I, I understood that what you're saying, that
because see,
every time different neural network convergence will take
more time, but timing also, you have to think in terms of
that time is not too much,
and parameter is anyway, reducing 30%
of the neurons you are dropping that, uh,
whatever weights are connected with those neurons,
you're not updating in the backward progression.
It is saving your time ultimately, I would say
Yes. So the number of parameters
will come down.
That's what, correct, correct. Yes. Yeah.
So, but the, um, when you go for this generalization also at
that time, so since we are using less number of neurons
and taking, um, this thing, so each
and everything, it'll have an own aeration.
So the generalization phenomenon will not counter effect,
No, actually, I tell you, I,
here I have shown you only three neurons, so it might be,
it looks at, okay, one neuron less, it'll not understand,
not generalize, but then when you have a hundred sub neurons
in a layer and you have such a hundred sub hidden layer,
in such cases, dropping those 30% actually helps
and generalize, uh, better than the, uh,
than fully connected rule.
Yeah. Uh, that is better than,
this is a generalization technique itself.
The dropout, yeah.
Okay, Sir.
Here I have a que a query, sir.
When we are, uh, dropping out,
we don't have a particular mechanism
to which neuron have to be dropped out.
We are randomly, uh, doing, sir,
but randomly when we are doing with 30% of it,
we may get some, we end up
with some result maybe in the next sequence.
Is it like a trial and error methods?
It's not trial and error.
In fact, we try to build multiple neural networks
like ensemble method.
Ensemble method is not a trial and error method, okay?
So instead of having a single person
who is doing the entire work,
I'll divide the work into the five persons.
I'll say, you also do this part. You, you understand? Okay?
So suppose I'll show you this object, you understand?
Okay, how does this look like to the other,
other, uh, person?
I'd say, okay, you understand this particular person
of the object, so you don't have to now remember everything.
You just have to remember only one aspect of the input,
and then collectively, all
of you can do a better, just a second.
No, what person of, uh,
neurons if feed report Just
a second, which would be the good?
Just,
Yeah. Oh, sorry.
So yes, you're asking something. Yeah.
What percentage of neurons have to be, uh, dropped out?
That can be
Actually this number vary between 0.2 to 0.5.
That is what I have seen most of the places. Okay?
Uh, although it's completely under the users
or programmers control.
Okay? We can control that. Okay?
How many you can see here, I have put here 0.3,
but this value, you can choose if you want,
you can write one, a hundred percent neuron would be
dropped, but that doesn't help, right?
So, uh, the good idea is that if you have over fitting,
uh, then you may be dropping, say that near to the 0.5,
0.0 0.4, 0.3.
If you have under fitting where the model has not learned,
well, then you don't drop much,
because if you drop all the network, what it'll learn
that it'll also the case, right? Yes,
Yes, yes.
Thank you.
Okay. So I guess then, uh, we have now some clarity
that why it is working
and, uh, obviously now your task is to go into little deeper
of the dropout, okay?
And understand more, uh, uh, uh, in depth
by some looking into some more resources
and batch normalization, right?
But at least, uh, through the experiment wise, we have seen
that that has made the, uh, uh, difference that my,
uh, obviously my training accuracy has not improved.
It is still at 88% by adding dropout or batch normalization.
But my test, uh, sorry, uh,
testing accuracy has not improved,
but training accuracy has decreased.
So obviously in one sense you can say
that training is decreased,
but then I, uh,
I was more bothering about over fitting rather than
improving the accuracy.
So now I have reduced the over fitting a little bit. Okay?
That is what, uh, that is what I said, that the, these, uh,
regularization techniques like dropout, ization
and L two regularization, they have helped us
to reduce the over fitting.
Now we've, we'll see that how to improve the accuracy. Okay?
There are two things I think, uh, which we can do from here.
First of, first of all, for, first of all,
we can think on improving the accuracy, uh, training
and testing accuracy, both as well as, uh, further, uh,
just, uh, reducing the over fitting, uh, over fitting.
That means that this gap is still a 5% or so.
Uh, we can still, uh, make it to equivalent.
So if both are 93, both are 88,
both are 90, that is also good.
Okay? So these are the two with these two objectives.
So now what we'll do is we'll dive into the next
module, okay?
And that we will see then, uh, with that,
we are now starting the C nnn, okay?
The convolutional neural network.
So the idea is that in this particular class,
I will not explain you the theory of the
CNN, okay?
Uh, I will not explain you the theory,
which will start in the next class.
Maybe sir, start,
I'm available, Okay? Okay. Okay. I'm,
I'm available.
Okay, sir. Then, uh, I'll, I'll project sir that, yeah,
Yeah, please, please, please.
Okay,
yeah.
Good evening. Are you able to hear me? Yes, sir. Yes, sir.
Good evening, sir.
Yes, sir. Good
Evening, sir. Sir, I'm good
evening. I'm outside.
I will not switch on video, so we'll just proceed. Okay?
Uh, thank you Sunil, uh, for no, uh,
clarifying all those important aspects of, uh, training the
deep field for neur networks and different approaches.
So, as Dr. Sunil was uh, mentioning, see,
one thing is if you just quickly see the journey of, uh,
deep learning, we started from the terminology
of neural networks, which are useful
in the deep, uh, learning era.
And then, uh, from multi-layer perceptron, we moved
to deep feed for neural network
and how the transition has happened, um, in terms
of, uh, training ability to train a deeper neural network,
and, uh, the significant performance achieved due to
that was demonstrated.
So then, so once that happened, then,
um, people started, uh, focusing more on, uh,
using deep learning models.
One of the thing they did was, um,
there was one grand challenge, uh, that is being, um,
organized, uh, at international level, uh,
what is called in the image processing,
what is called object classification.
If some of you are maybe working, um,
in the image processing, you may, uh, recall that
there is one publicly available large data sets
of crowdsource images, uh, put up
by public, what is called ImageNet dataset.
And, uh, in the image net data set, uh,
the goal is you can make use of that image net dataset for
what we call object classification.
Can you recognize
or classify the object that is present in a given image?
So this was the global challenge,
and people know across the world, they used to, um,
develop different methods
and submit,
but typically they are non neural network based methods
or non deep learning based methods.
Then, uh, for the first time,
the same Professor Hinton group, uh, developed a method
for object classification using convolution networks,
and showed that the
improvement in the object classification is significantly
higher compared to the non deep learning methods
that were proposed so far in the literature.
And this, the, uh,
demonstrated this, um, uh,
demonstrated the use of this conversion neural network.
Um, so
after that, no, then the whole world, uh,
started looking in that direction.
So how to make use of this commercial neural networks
for object classification.
With that, I think the rest is history.
You know, people, um,
all groups started using this commercial neural networks,
both, uh, the object classification task.
Then after that, uh, the other areas also pick it up.
And in the long run, what happened is
now the networks have become, uh,
models or two aspects.
One is for the feature extraction,
nonlinear feature extraction, not only
for image data, but for other data.
So speech or any other task we are doing.
Now, conventional networks have become
defacto models for feature extraction.
The other one is, uh, we can also use them
for classification tasks.
That is how think one of the just be
before beginning this, uh, the next shift
in the deep learning, uh, for people to adopt came
because of the significantly, uh, improved performance
shown by the commercial networks.
Okay, so that is, what is this one?
So with that input, um, let us see
how this conversion neural network
architecture was developed.
But, uh, of course, uh, the, the net,
the conversion network by itself was not invented
after this deep network.
This architecture was there itself in the SHA neural network
itself as an advanced neur network concept,
but the ability of that was demonstrated, uh,
in the object classification task,
the significant improvement in the performance.
Then later people went to know, um,
later people, uh, uh, started using that.
Okay, next, uh, slide.
Yeah, basically, uh,
the motivation for coming up
with conversion neural network was,
um, is it okay?
Okay. Conversion neur network was, um,
when originally this, uh,
neur network architecture was proposed, uh,
the motivation was suppose if the given data
or data points or features in there in available
two dimensional fashion, okay, just like an image, okay?
Of course, the, the main intention was for image only,
but now later it got extended to any data,
which you can arrange them in a grid manner,
two dimensional grid manner.
There. Also, you can use, uh, conversional networks.
See, the, the, the purpose of thinking like that was,
suppose if I take a, a two dimensional li data, like image,
humans perceive information as a result of looking into X
and Y direction, suppose I'd have a 2 56 crus, 2 56 image,
and I go to a portion called 16 cross 16 image where
I'm, I can make out the information present in the image due
to looking into
the spatial coordinates means in accent y
how the pixel intensities are changing.
So based on that, people will be able to,
uh, derive the information.
So then instead of that,
now suppose you take the image data two dimensional data,
2 56 crus 2 56,
and convert into one large, one dimension vector
and put it into deep feed for our level network,
which we were explaining earlier, you may not be able to
exploit that two dimensional information
that you are looking as a luxury by human perception.
This third process led to two people
coming up with proposing this new arch,
what are called, um, uh, neural networks, which exploit,
uh, uh, the information available in it, like, you know,
like the image that is the first motivation
for coming up with this architecture.
The second one is, uh,
the convolution operation.
See, um, it's so far in the deep feet
for neur neural network, the way from one layer
to the other, layer A signal flow C,
you are taken the output from the neurons
from the current layer.
They're multiplied by respective weight links
and, uh, the modified weight links
or modified in inputs from the respective neurons
by the weight links will we apply as input
to the neurons in the next layer.
Okay? So that is a simple matrix multiplication, if you want
to say it is a simple, if you think for a while, uh,
you are taking a vector, input vector, multiply
by a weight metrics to give the modified input
to the following layer of neurons,
that is the way we can
treat that thing.
That simple matrix multiplication operation in, in
between two layers of neuron is replaced
by an operation called convolution.
Okay? Of course,
this convolution is a very well known term
in electrical engineering.
Uh, they may not do exactly like that,
but they adopt that in principle.
Um, essentially when we go for, um, um,
convolution, how it is different compared to, uh,
simple matrix multiplication that we were doing in deep,
deep, um,
uh, there is, uh, uh, something called a, uh,
filter or a, uh, what we call, um,
um, instead of filter, whether I can use any other term,
I'm thinking a time being letter consider r
or we call it as a kernel, sorry, we call it as a kernel.
In the deep learning,
I have a kernel function.
Then what I do is the input data
that is given to the coming from the input layer
is multiplied by
this kernel, okay?
And then, uh, multiplied by kernel,
point by point, somewhat that value
and then pass it off.
There is a fundamental distinction which we
would appreciate here.
See, what we used to do in, uh, conventional deep feed
for new network is when one particular
input is selected, it is uniquely multiplied
by the link white
and given as input to the neuron in the next layer.
Whereas in the convolution, what we do is
you take a grid of data points, not one point.
You take a grid of data points, multiply with
by another kernel function there and some that all value,
and that is going as input to the next layer.
Let me say not single value multiplied
by one way is going to the next value.
It is first multiplied by a kernel,
and uh, we will see that kernel shape, all those things,
a multiple by kernel and some that value,
and that is called, that is equal into
what is called convolution, operation
theoretical engineering,
and then knows some, um, some additional things they do
to bring out what is called a, uh, no, uh, pulling
one layer just to smooth the operation.
There is an output function we follow that is all just
to mimic, mimic the neuron operation.
But however, the most important thing is, uh,
in a conation layer,
not one data point is uniquely possible.
A grid of data points together are multiplied by kernel,
and that multiplied
and somewhat value is given as our value
to the further inputs, further layers of the goal.
And that is the fundamental distinction.
So the output of this convolution of the input
with the kernel is the feature map that we call it as a
modified version of the data that we call it as a feature.
Okay? Just for example,
assume that I have a, a 2 56 plus 2 56 image,
and I divide into 16 plus 16 images
because my kernel is also 16 plus 16 shape,
and that kernel function is taken
and multiply with that first 16 plus 16 block.
And, uh, that multiplied somewhat value is given
as input a specific node in the output layer.
Similarly, the kernel is shifted to next 16,
cross 16 multiplier by the kernel wait multiplied
and somewhat value will be given
as input to the next new run.
That is how they do it in the con output of the convolution
of input with the kernel is a feature that
since uh, each data point is not passed
to the next layer, I take a grid of data points,
process it further,
and so we some, some sort of feature extraction,
we treat this as some sort of feature extraction.
Okay? Of course, uh,
then I said so many times this kernel, let me,
you know, one way, what do you mean by this?
Kernel means it is a grid of weight values, grid
of weight values, and how do you choose that weight values?
Either you can
prepare five, yes.
So, um, this, uh,
in the convolution operation,
the kernel, how do we use these?
You have a, uh, grid of values
either chosen randomly.
That is one way of people do it.
Other one is, uh, based on the domain knowledge.
For example, I want to extract specific type of features.
I will shape that grid values based on the shape
of the output.
I'm looking for example now in a given input grid data
points, I'm trying to extract the, uh,
orientations, which are at 45 degrees compared
to the horizontal line.
Then my grid value will be designed as
giving maximum value for that, uh, uh, 45 degree lights.
Okay? So that is what, uh, uh,
they do it in the case of uh, uh, other vertical lines.
The third method is you directly learn,
directly learn the data points
or the kernels from the actual input data.
So that is also people learn by, uh, process
that is also there, but we will not worry about that.
Kernel is a grid of weight values.
16 plus 16 weight value metrics will be there
that is multiplied for a given pixel.
Some of that value and send it. Okay?
And only another important point is
suppose if I take a deep feed following the network
between input layer
and the next layer, uh,
I have only one specific weight metrics, whereas here,
depending, you can have different number of kernels,
personal kernel, one far emphasizing horizontal lines,
kernel two far vertical lines, kernel three, four SL lines.
So in this way I can design the end number
of kernels for each case.
I can generate the output.
So that means to say, I can extract what types suppose.
On the other hand, I want
to extract circle like information
objects in the given image.
Then I will have a kernel of shape kernel weight values,
which is, which is mimicking the kernel shape
belonging to circles.
So that is what, uh, uh, we do.
So there can be multiple kernels.
Each kernel will represent a meaningful pattern once the
learning is coming that we can derive from the, uh, uh,
that one simple way know.
Suppose I want to derive a kernel.
One simple way is for a particular machine learning task,
suppose, uh, uh,
suppose I'm doing a face recognition task.
I, uh, I want
to extract a face like objects in a given email.
I take some thousand images
and take average of that thousand images.
That average value itself, I can treat it as a kernel.
So then no, it,
it contains a kernel whose shape his purpose is
to detect the face like shapes.
Okay? So that is what we are do, uh, do it.
Uh, we, of course we will see that in the know later slides.
But just to summarize, I have scroll few points here.
One is, uh, the in case of,
uh, defeat follow network that we discussed so far,
the process of signal flow from one layer to other layer
e ease through a simple weight metrics multiplication.
Whereas in case of con conversional network,
it is through a process called convolution.
Then that's why the name called Convolution neural network.
What is that convolution network.
You multiply grid of data points by kernels,
and those multiplied values are called ed,
and somewhat values are called as con convoluted values.
And those are taken to next layers.
And there can be multiple kernels possible depending on
what I want to extract, uh, process to the further layers.
So for each case, I do separate link kernel one is there.
I do the processing for kernel one
and produce it to the next layer, similar.
Next I check kernel two and process it for all the pixels
and given it to the next layer.
Essentially, the purpose of this kernel is to,
it is expected to represent a meaningful battle
provided we are learning from the
otherwise, you know, you have domain knowledge,
you can directly design synthetically that cardinal sand.
Okay, next slide.
So that's what I,
I told this why the name con conversion network came.
Generally, it is metrics
for new networks, whereas in case
of con conversional network, it employs convolution
as an alterna to metrics multiplication.
And the convolution layer
will have three operations, three stages.
We say one is the convolution of what I explained so far.
There is something called this
detection is essentially, no,
the controlled value is nothing
but the activation value that is possible
through an output function.
That is called a and then polling.
Polling is essentially it's some sort of,
uh, aging like thick.
What happens is in the two dimensional grade
two dimensional space,
the same information may not exactly fit into exact fixer
locations from one two grid values
to the other two grid values,
even though it represents the same class.
So to add some pause variation, all those things,
they initially came up with this polling,
but later people extended that
for any summing like activities that we, so, uh,
as I told no conversion is a mathematical operations, uh,
it is suitable for processing grid-like data,
especially two dimensional, uh, data.
Okay? Uh, even initially what they did is if you have one,
one dimensional time series data,
they map put into two dimensional.
Of course, two dimensional image data naturally comes
as a two dimensional data,
and 3D video data is converted into sequence
of, uh, 2D data.
Okay? So that is how people, um, have worked out that,
um, but um, the take home messages,
uh, you will, you will arrange the data in a two dimensional
manner to exploit the information available in
the next slide.
So the, the,
the engineering motivation for this conventional network is
so, can modify the structure of these neural networks
to mimic the deep learning strategy of human brain.
Of course, uh, there were some, uh,
cognitive science related, uh, um, um,
the cognitive science related, uh, uh, or research findings.
People started know whether to make it
as a two dimensional data, and we take motivation from that.
Also, essentially, uh, when,
when I take any information received to the human brain,
it'll be treated as if you go
to different learning centers in the brain, it'll be treated
as a two dimensional visualization of data.
Okay? So that is where people start.
Can we mimic, mimic this, uh,
deep learning strategy of the human brain?
So, which essentially, uh,
every data is treated in a two dimensional plane
and in a very layered manner
as you move from one layer to the next layer.
That was one of the, uh, motivation
that kept far why they are proposing,
because even though initial proposal was
for image processing, uh,
data comes in two dimensional pattern.
They wanted to give much more, uh, some appealing motivation
to conversional network concept.
They told human brain also processes
in a two dimensional fashion.
So accordingly, no, we can, uh, that is
how we are using this, uh, conation method.
That is what they said it. Okay?
And just for a reference, okay?
Uh, if you see no, this conation network network,
if you want, as I was telling it was first developed in
1980s by Anne Ko.
Okay? And, um, uh, ko, uh,
he also referred to some earlier work, aka
uh, he did not call it as commercial network work,
but, uh, something came cog Neurocog run,
he told Neurocog wrong, uh, so, uh, which is
he told we need a specialized in neuro network architecture
for dealing with images.
And that is what they call it as a neurocog run
was a very basic, uh, image recognition, uh,
neur network concept repository.
Okay? So that is what, uh, uh, one are the other motivations
for the next slide.
So specifically when you take the neuroscientific basis,
there is something called a primary work visual cortex, part
of the line responsible for visual scene processing.
So it performs significantly
advanced processing of visual input.
Uh, no, and what they observed
is this result.
Primary visual partex result was
when we observed some visuals dimensional region
of the brain gets illuminated, okay?
So
in terms of two dimensional data,
and there is a motivation
for proposing this in an architecture.
Next slide.
Uh, this primary visual cortex is arranged in a
spatial map, which has a two dimensional structure
measuring the structure of E Okay?
So the CNA capture this property
by having the features depending the two dimensional manner.
So I think these are all just to, uh,
uh, know some more details about
how people are using the primary visual cortex.
Okay? So
is essentially a process just right,
uh, uh, just, uh, uh, when, when I take this,
uh, in the primary
visual cortex, uh,
it contains many simple cells performing
in a small spatially localized, receptive field.
And, uh, accordingly, you know, they
designed these detector units of FCNN to
emulate these properties.
And similarly, they contain many complex cells, um,
uh, to respond to the feature cells
and which are inva
to small shifts in the positions of the feature.
And that means spite them to, uh, propose
what are called the pooling units.
Okay? So in that way, I see some,
some concepts which they observed in the
new cogniti studies.
So that is what they, uh, tried
to bring some neuroscientific basis for, uh,
proposing this conversion slide text,
and then this, uh, uh, neur network architectures.
Next slide.
Uh, people know generally it is believed that no,
the same principle, basic principles
of the primary visual card text played to other areas
of the visual strategy of detection,
followed by pulling is repeatedly applied to the brain.
So as we pass through multiple automatical layers
of the brain, and eventually you will find cells
that respond to some specific concept now,
in way into many transformation, something.
So the takeaway message from all these things is
the people when the seen recognition methods,
um, are, um, using Google network.
And one of the things they proposed was, uh,
using this two dimensional grid-like data.
Uh, one is from a layman visual observation,
we derive more information
by looking at the two dimensional play
and further, from a neurocognition basis,
neuroscientific neuroscientific basis, uh,
there are publishing results on
how visual scenes are processed in human brain.
Some of those studies are taken as a motivation for,
you know, coming up with this, uh,
conversion layer architecture.
Okay? Of course, these are only just
for an historical importance I'm telling.
But, uh, now once they started producing the result, we, uh,
through, we don't really care about that as a engineer,
just I will see, uh, how much it is, uh, used.
First argument,
we have a 16 plus 16 image
where yen is the index value
of the image,
and m is the what is the cardinal size you have?
Okay? Ah, secondly to, uh,
that is written return as the input.
And then the second argument we have, what is h
you know, uh, a two dimensional NAND m value.
We choose maybe one case is 16 plus 16 like that.
But first the position of the current
in the image, okay?
Ian represent the, all the values one to 16
that runs in the current.
Um, so essentially input is a
multidimensional array of data.
It's an command.
Um, kernel is also a multidi dimensional
array of parameters.
And uh, of course you can, if you go, if you go
beyond two dimensional, you can call it as sensors also,
um, when we are doing the convolution operation,
we assume that no,
even though a given image is 2 56 plus 2 56,
when I'm processing a first block of 16, class 16,
I assume that beyond that considered region of 16, class 16,
all outside values are assumed to be zeros.
So currently these kernel values also,
and then, uh, that's what you mentioned.
This functions xn m hn zoom to be zero everywhere
except for the grid of finance set of points.
Okay? Whatever that grid in the window of observation only,
we consider the values
and we assume all other values outside to be zeros.
And in the, in case of deep learning, the goal is
to learn the appropriate values
for the cardinal using a suitable, what is this?
X is the input data. How do you learn this?
HH that is the kernel.
And that is now, as I told, there are multiple strategies.
One is random. Um,
second one is domain knowledge based approach.
Third one is actually learn from the data. Next slide.
That is, um,
see the other, other, uh, uh, aspect
in case of, uh, conversion network keys, even though,
uh, I have multiple kernels.
So accordingly know your data gets expanded
as I move from one layer to the other layer, whereas
they exploit what is called a sparseness.
Okay? Um, I, if I take a traditional neural network,
it is just metrics multiplication by matrix
of parameter that weight values.
Whereas if I take conversion neural networks,
they typically have sparse interactions.
That means to say if I have 2 56 class, 2 56
image, original image, I can create a sparseness.
Depending on the shift I do.
Suppose I make a grid of 16 across 16,
and I shift that grid every 16 pixels, then
I will have only 16 across 16 values
coming to the next level.
Okay? And that is what is, that is
how I can create the sparse interaction.
Okay? You, uh, so as a result of that,
no, you can, uh, still keep the number of parameters
to a manageable level.
Um, so you can, uh,
you can store accordingly.
You can store only fewer parameters,
which will both reduce the memory requirement of the model
and improves the statistical efficiency.
That's what, uh, big in input is.
Output is K and traditional neur network.
You have M cross N,
and K cross N with, uh,
the later results in a far few parameters
and less competitions in a deep conversion network.
Uh, you need in the deeper layers may interact indirectly,
uh, with the larger portion of the input.
Um, uh, the meaning of this last statement is,
suppose I in the first layer, I will have,
uh, 16, class 16 from the original image,
I'm only looking at 16, class 16, whereas
if I have the same 16 class, 16 in the second layer,
uh, the inputs for that are
16 such blocks from the previous lane.
That means to say it is a bigger window for observation
compared to the previous lane.
That's what in a deep manner,
as you move deeper into the layers, even though
you use the grid size, small value,
but uh, the input for
that is coming from a larger window from the previous layer.
Okay? So accordingly, you know,
as you move deeper into the conventional layer layer,
you will have, uh,
it is combining information from a larger dimension
to convert into a smooth feature.
That's what, so first layer, you put 16 plus 16
grid is used for, uh, feature mapping, smoothing
the same 16 plus 16.
The second layer, maybe it'll be 64, cross 64,
it is used for construction.
Next, next, um,
uh, the important points
that support conventional network is spatial knowledge.
I use class specific information, um,
in spatial domain, uh, as I told for image,
and it'll have APAR interaction.
The information in spatial domain is only among neighborhood
of pixels, our local region,
and we'll store only in few parameters, okay?
Because I can use the same terminal
across all the multiplications.
So I currently know the number, number of weight parameters.
If you treat NEL values as the weight parameters, the number
of weight parameters will also be less sharing cheaper.
See, these are, uh, know,
because generally people find it, uh, when the proposal,
this combination matter of model, oh, you are going
to prove the mission.
Suddenly the ion network
will be more compared to one dimension case.
And there are like that people felt.
No, we have to, there are some advantages of, uh,
using conversion network.
One is the spatial knowledge. The second one, the spots in,
sorry, we lost your voice.
Oh, okay. Yeah.
So, so Neil, maybe, yeah, we'll stop here. We'll,
Hi. Yes, sir.
If we can continue in the next class, uh,
we can stop here if they have any query they can ask. Yes.
Yeah, maybe we'll stop here in the next session. See
Any queries so far?
Anyone?
Uh, we'll again, uh, there was some connection laws in
between, but we'll repeat it again next.
I think we'll do in the next session. Yes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Thank you, sir. Thank you, sir.
Thank you, sir. Thank you, sir. Thank you, sir.
Sir, thank you, sir. Thank you, sir. Thank you, sir.
Thank you, sir.